ينضم الينا من رام الله اللواء الركن
المتقاعد واصف عريقات الخبير بالشؤون
العسكريه والاستراتيجيه سيد واصف عريقات
نبدا معك من ما اعلنته وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه عن ان القتلى الثلاثه في صفوف
جيش الاحتلال هم من كتيبه جفعاتي احدهم
نائب قائد سريه وقتلوا في شمالي القطاع
بدايه المكان الذي قتلوا فيه خاصه ان
الجانب الاسرائيلي كان قد قال انه سيطره
على شمالي
القطاع يعني هذا يؤكد بانه لم يسيطر على
شمال القطاع وما دام ان هناك قتلى
اسرائيليين هذا دليل ساطع بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي صحيح انه وصل ولكنه انسحب
ولماذا انسحب انسحب لانه كان هناك مقاومه
باسله استبسل وقامت بتنفيذ عمليات نصبت
كمائن وقنص دبابات واشتبكت مع الجنود
الاسرائيليين ب عن مسافه صفر وقد بثت
كتائب المقاومه الفلسطينيه ال افلام فيديو
تثبت ذلك وانها استطاعت ان تقتل عدد كبير
من الجنود والاسرائيليين وخاصه من هذا
اللواء جفعاتي وهو ذات ذات اللواء ذات
النخبه التي كان اللواء الجولاني يتصف بها
وانا اعتقد انه ما من يقاتل الان في
الخطوط الاماميه كلهم من لواء الجولاني
الجبعي الوحدات الخاصه المظليين لانهم
حقيقه لا يعتمدوا في هذه المراحل بعد ان
جربوا قدرات المقاومين الفلسطينيين
واستبسال في الميدان وتطورهم النوعي في
القتال لا لا يعني لا يامنون لجنود
الاحتياط لذلك من يقاتل هم جنود النخبه
ومن يهزم ومن يقتل منه عدد كبيرهم من جنود
النخبه وهذا ان دل على شيء يدل على ان
قدرات المقاومه الفلسطينيه وتطورها النوعي
وتكيفها مع الميدان هو الاساس وخاصه انهم
يعرفون طبيعه العدو ويعرفون تكتيكاته
واساليبه الحربيه لذلك يستدرجون الى مناطق
تقتيل ويشتبك معهم المسافه صفر وكما جرى
بال بالعمليات السابقه التي شاهدناها في
مقاطع الفيديو سواء كان استهداف دبابه
المركبه باللغ الذي يزن 25 غم من هذا
المقاتل الذي ذهب وضعه تحت الدبابه بشكل
مباشر وفجرها واضافه الى تفجير المبنى على
على راس جنود الجيش جيش الاحتلال الذين
كانوا يريدون تفجير هذا المبنى وتم تحويله
عليهم انا بتقديري هذه المهارات الميدانيه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه هي عباره عن اعجاز
عسكري وهي حروب تدرس في الاكاديميات
العسكريه شكرا لك واصف عراقات الخبير
بالشؤون العسكريه والاستراتيجيه كنت معنا
من رام الله